what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we got some
really exciting news about an upcoming
marvel disney plush show that i am
personally super excited for the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
which has been confirmed to be coming
this year and apparently it's going to
be introducing some new characters to
the mcu that you may not be expecting
like perhaps santa claus this is a big
rumor going around right now and it
looks like mark hamill could actually be
the actor playing santa claus i
personally really hope this happens it
would be a great way to end 2022 that is
going to be just jam-packed with marvel
projects we are getting a ton of disney
plus content this year in 2022 moon
night miss marvel she-hulk what if
season 2 has been confirmed to be coming
out this year the guardians of the
galaxy holiday special and secret
invasion sometime in 2022 as well not to
mention the movies that are also coming
out as well this year doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness thor love and
thunder and black panther 2 wakanda
forever it's a great year for marvel
fans but right now james gunn is
praising the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special as one of the best
things he's ever done and at one point
in time he did say that you're gonna
have to watch this to actually know
what's going on in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3. so it is going to be an
important show here's a direct quote
from james gunn about the holiday
special it's in canon it's about the
guardians you're gonna learn stuff that
you need to learn before volume three
and it's great i'm really happy with it
so basically take this as a short
guardians of the galaxy movie now i hope
thor shows up and we do actually have a
new look at thor's costume for thor love
and thunder that was actually revealed
by hallmark for a christmas ornament
which is kind of weird because we're not
anywhere near christmas but we'll
definitely talk about that but let's
talk about how james gunn says that this
is the greatest thing that he's ever
done the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special on twitter comicbook.com posted
a quote from james gunn saying that
james gunn calls guardians of the galaxy
holiday special the greatest thing that
he's ever done with the quote by james
gunn saying it's totally ridiculous we
all completely love it which is
fantastic because that's what the
guardians of the galaxy are a completely
ridiculous group of superheroes that we
love now james gunn actually went on to
kind of talk to people on twitter and
give a little bit of information about
what to expect from the holiday special
in response to james gunn's quote saying
it's the best thing that he's ever done
a user on twitter brian atkins added
james gunn saying not that there's
anything wrong with it but is this true
james gunn i've always loved guardians
of the galaxy and peacemaker was on
another level so if this is true holy
crap in which james gunn replied i did
say that but i'm prone to hyperbole and
usually think the current thing i'm
working on is the best thing i've ever
done that said i really do love it and i
think people are going to be very happy
this christmas with what we're creating
so james gunn did say that he did say
it's the greatest thing that he's ever
done now of course he explains that he
can get caught up in the moment like any
of us can but still the fact that he
said it's the greatest thing he's ever
done combined with the fact that it's in
canon and we have to know it we have to
watch this special to know what's
happening in guardians of the galaxy 3
means that this is going to be pretty
special james gunn continued to respond
to more fans clarifying some things
about the special like how long is it
going to be and where to watch it james
gunn tweeted it is a tv special on
disney plus it is tv special link now tv
specials kind of vary in time but they
typically are around about 90 minutes
long so this isn't like a disney plus
series there's not going to be more than
one episode it's one thing it's a tv
special which means it's kind of like a
mini movie and again it's going to be
very important because james gunn also
tweeted more than one great new mcu
characters will be introduced in the
guardians of the galaxy holiday special
which is awesome and speaking of new
characters there's a rumor going around
right now and it's based off of
speculation on something mark hamill and
james gunn have done that mark hamill
could be playing santa claus in the
holiday special which could be one of
those great mcu characters that james
gunn was talking about santa claus now
what's very interesting and kind of epic
is that santa claus is an actual
character from marvel comics so it's not
like they're just taking santa claus
from the christmas holiday and putting
him into the mcu he is an actual
character and not gonna lie he's kind of
actually really op he's kind of insanely
powerful it depends on what story you're
reading but there are a lot of instances
where he's really strong for example in
one storyline with the x-men cerebro
detected the most powerful mutant ever
registered in the new york's rockefeller
center now this mutant was also detected
by the brotherhood of evil mutants and
of course they also sought out this
mutant so the x-men and the brotherhood
of evil mutants both went to the
rockefeller center which of course
resulted in a battle but check out how
this ended santa briefly transformed the
brotherhood of evil mutants into
inanimate toys he then teleported the
x-men away and then he erased both
groups memories of his involvement and
then he made it snow for the first time
on christmas in years the dude kind of
literally defeated the brotherhood of
evil mutants then in another story he
actually saved the entire city of new
york from hate monger then at one point
he actually teams up with she-hulk one
of santa's abilities is the ability to
know who is naughty and nice and at one
point he decides to use this ability to
become a great detective where he went
by the name nick saint christopher so
there are a lot of cool stories now like
i said the rumor going around is that
mark hamill could be playing santa claus
and recently somebody made some fan art
of mark hamill as santa claus and put it
on twitter where both james gunn and
mark hamill liked the tweet now of
course this could just be a coincidence
and they could like this just by liking
the idea of it and it may not be true
but consider this it was rumored for an
extremely long time that mark hamill
would be playing the high evolutionary
and guardians of the galaxy vol 3. and
while we're pretty sure at this point in
time that chukwudi awgi is going to be
playing the high evolutionary one has to
wonder where these rumors and reports
actually came from now james gunn and
mark hamill are actually very close
friends and keep in mind right now star
wars is a part of disney and mark hamill
is a part of star wars and marvel is a
part of disney as well so if james gunn
wanted his buddy mark hamill in a movie
or tv special it wouldn't be that hard
they're all really part of the same
family so perhaps some of these reports
were a little bit off perhaps mark
hamill is in a guardians of the galaxy
project it's just not guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 it's the guardians of the
galaxy holiday special where he could be
playing santa claus which is kind of a
pretty cool thought but let me know what
you think about this now speaking of
holiday specials and holiday related
things like i mentioned we do have a new
look at thor's costume for thor love and
thunder from a christmas ornament it's
very different than what we have
recently seen thor wear in avengers
in-game his suit was really dark it was
pretty much dark gray dark silver and
black but here we kind of have a little
bit more of a classic thor look in a way
where his suit is mostly blue and gold
and check this out he's wearing his
helmet and it looks like it has the
wings on top of it but overall this suit
actually looks really really good and i
think it's a good twist on his comic
costume now i don't know if thor is
going to appear in the guardians of the
galaxy holiday special since thor love
and thunder is before both the holiday
special and guardians 3 but i think if
he were in the holiday special it would
be even more hilarious but let me know
what you think about all of this in the
comments down below would you like to
see mark hamill play santa claus now
that i know it's a possibility i
personally really really want this to
happen but what about you don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
stay up to date on all of the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
me